there's something about ego in the human
mind that seems to be corrupted by power
so when you say global governance
that
terrifies me
more than the possibility of war because
it's uh i think that people will be less
terrified than you are right now and let
me try to
paint the picture from their point of
view this isn't my point of view but i
think it's going to be a widely shared
point of view yes this is two devil's
advocates arguing two devils okay
so
for the last half century and into the
continuing future we actually have had
a strong
elite global community that shares a lot
of values and beliefs and has
created a lot of convergence in global
policy
so if you look at electromagnetic
spectrum or
medical experiments or pandemic policy
or
nuclear power energy or regulating
airplanes or just in a wide range of
area in fact the world
has very similar regulations and rules
everywhere and it's not a coincidence
because they are part of a world
community where people get together at
places like davos et cetera where world
elites
want to be respected by other world
elites and they have a you know
convergence of opinion and that produces
something like global governance but
without a global center this is sort of
what human mobs or communities have done
for a long time that is humans can
coordinate together on shared behavior
without a center by having gossip and
reputation within a community of elites
and that is what we have been doing and
are likely to do a lot more of so for
example
you know one of the things that's
happening say with the war in ukraine is
that this world community of elites has
decided that they disapprove of the
russian invasion and they are
coordinating to
pull resources together from all around
the world in order to oppose it and they
are proud of that
sharing that opinion and their and their
feel that they are morally justified in
their stance there and um
that's the kind of event that actually
brings world elite communities together
where they
they come together and they push a
particular policy and position that they
share and that they achieve successes
and
the same sort of passion animates global
elites with respect to say global
warming
or global poverty and other sorts of
things and they are in fact making
progress on those sorts of things
through
shared
global community of elites
and in some sense they are slowly
walking toward global governance slowly
strengthening various world institutions
of governance but cautiously carefully
watching out for the possibility of a
single power that might corrupted
i think a lot of people over the coming
centuries will look at that history and
like it
it's uh interesting thought
and thank you for playing that devil's
advocate there
but i think
the elites too easily lose touch
of the morals
that
uh the best of human nature and power
corrupts sure but everything is their
view is the one that determines what
happens
their view may
still end up there even if you or i
might criticize it from that point of
view so from a perspective of minimizing
human suffering
elites
can use
topics of the war in ukraine
and climate change and all of those
things
to
sell an idea
to the world
and uh with disregard to the amount of
suffering it causes
their actual actions so like you can
tell all kinds of narratives that's the
way propaganda works right hitler
uh really sold the idea that everything
germany is doing is either it's the
victim is defending itself against the
cruelty of the world and it's actually
trying to bring out
about a better world
so
every power center thinks they're doing
good and so this is uh
this is the positive of competition of
not of having multiple power centers
this kind of gathering of elites
makes me very very very nervous the
dinners
the the meetings in the closed rooms
i don't know
i another
but remember we talked about separating
our cold analysis of what's likely or
possible from what we prefer and so
that's this isn't exactly enough time
for that we might say
i would recommend we don't go this route
of a world strong world governance and
uh because i would say it'll preclude
this possibility of becoming rabbi
aliens of filling the next nearest
million galaxies for the next billion
years with vast amounts of
activity and interest and value
of life out there that's the thing we
would lose by deciding that we wouldn't
expand that we would stay here and keep
our comfortable
shared governance
so you wait you think that
global
governance
is
makes it more likely or less likely that
we expand out into the universe less
so okay this is the key this is the key
point right
right so screw the elites
so right we want to wait do we want to
expand
so again i want to separate my neutral
analysis from my evaluation and say
first of all i have an analysis that
tells us this is a key choice that we
will face and that it's key choice other
aliens have faced out there and it could
be that only one in 10 or 100
civilizations chooses to expand and the
rest of them stay quiet and that's how
it goes out there and we face that
choice too
and
it'll happen sometime in the next 10
million years maybe the next thousand
but the key thing to notice from our
point of view is that
uh even though you might like our global
governance you might like the fact that
we've come together we know we no longer
have massive wars and we no longer have
destructive competition
and that we could continue that
the cost of continuing that would be to
prevent interstellar colonization that
is once you allow interstellar
colonization then you've lost control of
those colonies and whatever they change
into they could come back here and
compete with you back here
as a result of having lost control and i
think if people value that
global governance and
global community and regulation and all
the things it can do enough they would
then want to prevent interstellar
colonization i want to have a
conversation with those people i believe
that both for
uh humanity for the good of humanity for
what i believe is good in humanity and
for expansion exploration
um innovation
distributing the centers of power is
very beneficial so this whole meeting of
elites and i've met i've gotten i've
been very fortunate to meet
uh quite a large number of elites
they make me nervous
because
it's easy to lose touch of reality
i'm nervous about that in myself
to make sure that you never lose touch
um as you get
sort of older
wiser
you know how you generally get like
disrespectful of kids kids these days
no the kids are
but
here's a stronger case for their
position so i'm i'm going to play for
the for the elites yes well for the for
the
for the limiting of expansion and for
the regulation of of um behavior so just
okay can i link on that sure so you're
saying those two are connected
so we the human civilization and alien
civilizations come to a uh a crossroads
they have to decide do we want to expand
or not
and connected to that do we want to give
a lot of power to a central elite right
do we want to
uh
distribute the power centers which is
naturally connected to the expansion
when you expand you distribute the power
if say over the next thousand years we
fill up the solar system right we go out
from earth and we colonize mars and we
change a lot of things
within a solar system still everything
is within reach that is if there's a
rebellious colony around neptune you can
throw rocks at it and smash it and then
teach them discipline okay
that work for the birds central control
over the solar system is feasible
but once you let it escape the solar
system it's no longer feasible but if
you have a solar system that doesn't
have a central control maybe broken into
a thousand different political units in
the solar system
then
any one part of that that allows
interstellar colonization and it happens
that is
interstellar colonization happens when
only one party chooses to do it and is
able to do it and that's what it is
therefore so we can just say in a world
of competition
if interstellar colonization is possible
it will happen and then competition will
continue and that will sort of ensure
the continuation of competition into the
indefinite future
that's and competition
we don't know but competition could take
violent forms in many productive forms
and the case i was going to make is that
i think one of the things that most
scares people about competition is not
just that it creates holocausts and
death on massive scales is that it's
likely to
change who we are and what we value yes
so this is the other thing with power
as we grow
as human civilization grows becomes
multi-planetary
multi-solar system potentially
how does that change us do you think i
think the more you think about it the
more you realize it can change this a
lot
so first of all this is pretty dark by
the way well
it's just honest
right so i'm trying to do that but i
think the first thing you should say if
you look at history just human history
over the last ten thousand years
if you really understood what people
were like a long time ago you'd realize
they were really quite different
ancient cultures
created people who were really quite
different most historical fiction lies
to you about that
it often offers you modern characters in
an ancient world but if you actually
study history you will see just how
different they were and how differently
they thought
and that's they've changed a lot many
times and they've changed a lot across
time so i think the most obvious
prediction about the future is
even if that you only have the
mechanisms of change we've seen in the
past you should still expect a lot of
change in the future but we have a lot
bigger mechanisms for change in the
future than we had in the past
so um i have this book called the age of
m work love and life and robots rule the
earth and it's about what happens if
brain emulations become possible so a
brain emulation is where you take a
actual human brain and you scan it in
fine spatial and chemical detail to
create
a computer simulation of that brain
and then those computer simulations of
brains are basically citizens in a new
world they work and they vote and they
fall in love and they get mad and they
lie to each other and this is a whole
new world and my book is about analyzing
how that world is different than our
world
basically using competition as my key
level of analysis that is if that world
remains competitive that i can figure
out how they change in that world what
they do differently than we do
and it's very different
and it's different in ways that are
shocking sometimes to many people
in ways some people don't like i think
it's an okay world but i have to admit
it's quite different and that's just
one technology
if we add you know dozens more
technologies changes into the future you
know we should just expect
it's possible to become very different
than who we are i mean in the space of
all possible minds our minds are a
particular architecture a particular
structure a particular
set of habits and they are only you know
one piece in a vast face of
possibilities the space of possible
minds is really huge
you